okay
bye
welcome back to launch pad i'm christian
reddy your friendly neighborhood
astronomer and it's great to see you
here
live and in persons or
in digital binary bits whatever it is
we're using
so i am happy to welcome you tonight and
we're going to be meeting tonight this
is not part of our regular
planetarium meeting by the way at towson
university instead this is just an
informal
hello how you all doing type of thing
because i got a buddy of mine who's
coming on tonight who's going to be
talking to us
about testing some of the fundamental
properties of physics some of the things
we've always taken for granted
or assumed was always true but maybe
never really fully formulated the proper
test for it really just trying to get to
the nitty gritty of our universe
he is in fact the author of
losing the nobel prize a story of
cosmology ambition and the perils of
science's highest honor he is in fact
the man himself
dr brian keating hello brian good
evening
hi chris how are you doing tonight i'm
doing great and i'm getting
an echo in my uh in my ears
so i've gotta i gotta just make a little
adjustment here
pardon me shut off
i could also plug in my headphones yeah
if you don't mind putting in your
headphones that would be
that would be super helpful absolutely
all right yep everybody this is live and
we didn't exactly get 100
of all of our stuff sorted out just
ahead of time i do want to say hello and
just uh welcome a few folks here on a
welcome
jan paf medic good to see you lucky lucy
hi
how you doing sir we also have
create you saying i seriously love that
book title
it really does and there's quite a story
behind that create you got to check that
out
all right let me see if i can also say
hi to some other folks i got
hi christian hello everyone it's good to
see you and
brian you've got your earbuds in but i
honestly have no idea
why i'm getting this wretched echo
i hear you just fine part of me as i
okay brian you there yeah i'm here
okay i'm hearing the entire thing play
out and i think i know what the problem
is
i know what the problem is you see i
actually had my own live stream up
in another browser and i wanted to see
the
comments come in and i actually had my
own browser talking to me and it was
really really strange i hope everybody
else can hear me
and bear with me as i learn how to live
stream goods
all right let's talk a little bit about
uh what's going on brian so you've uh
you've written this book about losing a
nobel prize i know we spoke about that
the last time we had you on
okay good i'm i'm delighted to hear that
uh
sound is good there and it was purely
just on my end so that's wonderful to
know thank you
anyway brian i'd like to ask you a
little bit about
how you go about investigating some of
the fundamental properties of
physics itself and testing it and let me
guess you're going to tell me it has to
do with a comet
cosmic microwave background aren't you
well in part it's everybody's favorite
fossil
and we astronomers as you know are
nothing if not
archaeologists of time using our time
machines aka our telescopes i have one
here
that is my first telescope this is about
45 years old no this is my first one
this is i think a pirate used it and
dropped the lens out of it but
you know when galileo first looked up at
the heavens he was using a telescope
not unlike the one i just showed you
here he is now my friends at the
unemployed philosopher's guild
sent me these uh beautiful finger
puppets of galileo
we'll talk about einstein we'll talk
about there you go
are you giving me the finger you know
galileo got in a little trouble for
doing that himself galileo
i i wear galileo on my middle finger for
a very
specific reason anyway
go ahead yes uh you and other christians
just kidding just kidding now uh that's
a double
entendre as they would say uh so what we
try to do
is use these telescopes to learn about
phenomena that are
insufficiently uh distant
to check in our laboratory so imagine
there's some phenomenon that
changes the nature of the properties of
light
or changes the nature of the properties
of gravity
well these things might be true but we
might be
unable to measure them here on a
laboratory and
on earth such as my laboratory here at
uc san diego
so instead we have been given one of the
world's
if not the universe's greatest possible
laboratory and that's the universe
itself
and so there are distant phenomena that
are exotic that could
provide ideal laboratories for testing
matter under extreme circumstances for
testing
the laws of electromagnetism for testing
the principles that
underpin all of modern physics and that
is something that is uh really a key
ingredient in einstein's theory of
relativity
and that's something that we'll talk
about today which is a special kind of
symmetry known as
lorentz invariants and i have been
obsessed with this for years or decades
now
and we're finally getting to the point
where we might be able to test it and
see if the universe
violates this closely held principle
so let's talk about what is lorenzen
variance obviously the name implies
something shall
always be the same in different frames
of reference
but let's go ahead and just break that
down a little bit and
talk about what that is and how we might
go about testing it
yeah so uh the most simple
way to encapsulate the essence of what
lorenzen variance
is is to say the universe doesn't care
about you i'm sorry
christian i care about you your fans
care about you
i care i care about everybody yeah the
universe couldn't care less about you
doesn't care where you live
uh what what your color is what country
you are
yeah it doesn't care and in fact
i find very important such as what day
today is
we uh we we have to make an appointment
to schedule this live stream with your
audience well we had to set the time
the universe doesn't care about that the
universe goes on about its business
and really doesn't respect anything
about us uh from our perspective because
it is
just ours in other words if i take
observations of the planet uh jupiter on
a wednesday
and i come back you know a day later and
those general observations maybe the
exact phenomenon
won't be the same but the general
properties
will not vary from day to day from hour
to hour
from second to second and so one way
that you could test that principle of
of perhaps the uninterested universe
is to look for variations perhaps there
is some universal time
that the universe is aware of or some
universal energy or
some universal length scale or color or
gravitational effect
and we don't believe those are true and
in fact that is the basis
of einstein's theory of what's called
special relativity
that the universe doesn't care what your
reference frame
is you and i have equal share and equal
claim
to being the center of our own universe
which means there is no center of the
universe if
every observer can claim to be the
central observer that means
none of them are and that is the key
realization
that led us to try to test whether or
not this is true because if it's true
then everything is well and all of
physics on which we base
all of modern laws and and everything
you teach to your students
would be held near and dear and still
correct but if it's wrong
then this guy is wrong and that would
have
unique implications for all of our
understanding of science
that's not just physics that's uh it's
extremely
um relevant i mean yeah as you said that
is as
far that is as far to the core as you
can possibly go we essentially
claim or we believe that we live in the
universe so we hold no special place we
hold no special
uh privilege of position or in theory
uh moment in time except for the fact
that we had to wait for the universe to
get old enough
to have us around uh but we
are now thinking about you we're
basically saying look if this is not
correct then there actually
is an absolute frame of reference is
that where you're is that what you think
that way well we there have been claims
that there
are absolute frames of reference and
this goes back a long ways it goes back
to
even the pre uh pre you know industrial
and scientific revolution theories
of none other than galileo himself and
that was
first kind of elucidated in what i
consider the best
the second best i should say second best
science book ever written
and that is of course the dialogue
on the two chief world systems
and in this book which is a written the
forward of which is written by none
other than a man by the name of albert
einstein
uh he calls it one of the most important
books in history too
not just for its scientific content but
for the way that it presents these
arguments in a way that people could
understand it
it was written in italian it was written
in a way that the common person could
understand it in the form of a dialogue
between multiple characters that were
loosely based on real human beings
and this is the famous book that got
galileo into a little bit of hot water
with the church we don't have to get
into that necessarily
but the main idea of this polemical book
was to establish the scientific basis
of the copernican theory namely that the
earth is not the center of the universe
and that the sun is the object around
which the earth and all the other
planets go
and that was revolutionary no pun
intended because that's the title of of
course copernicus's book
and his hypothesis on the revolutions of
the heavenly spheres
but what galileo wanted to do is take
that hypothesis
that was just a theory a theory
like the theory of evolution uh which
has no basis no i'm just kidding
i believe in the theory of everything
i'm just testing you christian uh
but the the theory of uh of the
copernicus
it doesn't matter what we believe
actually
the reality wins 100 of the time right
exactly but anyway go ahead i didn't
interrupt you go ahead
yeah so galileo wanted to establish
scientifically using the scientific
method
to establish evidence deductions
inductions hypothesis
correcting and consensus the
cornerstones
of the scientific method and he's really
considered the first scientist
of the modern age to employ it and it's
interesting that
when he set out to do it his job was
trying to prove that the earth went
around
the sun and not the other way around and
uh by
a real kind of series of events that are
almost comically hilarious he both
um attributed the the effects that would
be the
the most proving cause the most strong
evidence for his hypothesis
he made a completely fallacious argument
uh that we now know to be completely
wrong and that was
uh the original title of his book uh
this was the title that he eventually
was forced to publish by the church
the dialogue concerning the two chief
world systems
but his original title get this i
consider this for losing the nobel prize
also
but his original title christian do you
know what it was no i don't
actually it was very catchy it was on
the flux
and reflux of tides in the earth's
rivers
lakes and ferns ferns i don't know if
they have ferns by you yeah
they're in the east coast uh not well we
have a few here and there but you know i
mean i i think
burns and maryland clearly yeah we have
maryland ferns
but clearly clearly the church did not
want galileo on the new york times
bestseller list that's why they made
them go with on
on dialogue uh yeah um
yeah did the church not realize that
they that this book was kind of trolling
them and that they were making it by
changing the title they were making it
that much more accessible and likely to
be read by people
well it's interesting because galileo
was formally
charged with violating an injunction
back in 1616
and that was to not teach the copernican
system it was fine to
research it it was fine to observe it
and this book i should say was published
in 1632
so 16 years later and it took him the
better part of a decade to actually
write it it's actually 587 pages long
with footnotes and introductions so uh
it's quite a lengthy book i have read it
uh cover to cover
and there's some dry parts but there's
some parts that are just spectacular
and i think what threatened the church
so much is that
he unlike the first book that really
elucidated the
image that we associate with galileo
namely the moons of jupiter
the craters on the moon of earth the
phases of venus
all those but uh all those observations
were made in a book called sidirius
nuncius
and i know that you know latin and speak
it as a fluent native
uh but i don't but anyway that book is
written in latin that was not written
in english or sorry in english it wasn't
written in italian so he was permitted
to espouse those ideas because that
wasn't considered teaching
it would be like your your uh your
university says you know
christian you could teach as long as you
do so only in python three
and then you're like well python three
it's not really as good as you know
fortran
yeah whatever and so you misconstrue
their direct order now that's that's
permissible with some
university administrators think that
they have more power than the pope i
know i suffer from that sometimes but
nevertheless the pope was the most
powerful person in the world at that
time a governmental
military force etc and they had the
power to
basically accuse him of teaching it
which was a uh condemnation which
carried with it a penalty of uh of
essentially uh suspicion of heresy which
could be a capital offense either
leading to
to execution or to you know lifelong
imprisonment
and of course he was in prison but it
was a pretty sumptuous
surroundings where he was imprisoned
actually did
a conference on the basis of relativity
which we'll talk about
uh just in a second the galileo is the
first person to really investigate what
we now call
relativity and i hosted this conference
with friends
outside of florence at galileo's prison
quote unquote
which is in the mountains uh or the
hills behind florence what's known as
archetree
and it's a beautiful sumptuous villa
with grapevines and orchards and so
forth and i always joke you know
bernie madoff would kill literally to do
his uh
his home imprisonment there so uh the
the what what
what galileo did that was so brilliant
in this book uh
is multi-faceted because it reveals
science
as done by human beings not only by as i
call them
walking wikipedias he was human he had
human foibles
he had failings he had biases he had
prejudices just like you do just like i
do
and science is done by human beings so
why would we expect
science to be free from such biases i
think it's
even more relevant today than ever and
that's why
we have a peer review among other things
plus not to mention just general
scrutiny from the community as well as
the public in some cases so with that
if we fast forward by 400 some odd years
yeah well let's go first where does this
take us slides yeah let's look at the
slides that i show
okay because this is the main argument
that still holds water no pun intended
today which is this is taken from
physics central which is from the aps
and it shows what's known as galilean
relativity in which galileo said
that if you were in a boat underneath
the surface of the boat
and you blocked out all the light etc
and the boat was moving in uniform
motion and there were no waves to speak
of
then this vector up top the black arrow
is showing the direction of motion
then anything that you did any
observation any experiment that you did
would have the same outcomes as it would
on
stable dry land in other words you could
do
an experiment where you drop a ball at
t1 and it lands at t2 as shown here
and their position of other objects at
rest to you
would measure different uh different
behavior of that ball from their
reference frame
but you could add together the velocity
if you threw the ball
you could throw the ball inside there's
galileo he could throw the ball also
and the velocity of the ship would be
added to the velocity of the throwing of
the ball
and so he said you basically couldn't do
an experiment
on a boat at constant velocity which
would reveal the motion of the boat
which we now know to be true uh there
are subtle effects to
um you know if you look think about the
coriolis effect
perhaps eugene very good as i'm saying
it eugene cidale gets an extra
bonus point the coriolis effect their
effects you've got a good audience i
i know i have an awesome audience and
they're watching too but i i
yeah that's great i i i'm so proud of
them
so that's a subtle effect that would
reveal non what's called a non-inertial
nature of the motion of the earth and
rotation but let's ignore that galileo
ignored that
um and so their thing stood for 400 you
know 300 years at least until
galileo came about and said well that
might be true at low
velocities but if you increase the boat
speed near the velocity of light
other things start to take over and in
such a
in such a situation you could not claim
that physics would physics would still
not depend on your relative motion
and no one observer could claim to be
the
most important observer in the universe
and that was the underpinnings
of the lorentz uh transformation right
we expect everything to be the same
in all frames of reference okay but
after
um by the way by the way uh just
if the story sounds awfully familiar to
me and i'm sure that anybody else
who's learned about relativity and
things like that you know einstein was
using a train
galileo's on a boat same thing yeah
yeah isn't that funny and and we've all
had that experience right where
i literally have had that on a train on
a boat uh
on a plane as it taxis away from the
from the gate you know you feel like
the other objects are moving and you
feel like you are stationary
and so but think back then look we have
the benefit of standing on the shoulders
of these giants
they didn't know it and so uh but but
remember what galileo wanted to
wanted to really prove is the diagram
ignore the lumineferous ether for one
second but he want to prove that the
earth is moving around the sun
in other words you the earth if it was
moving in this fashion
and if the orbital radius were large
enough then effectively
it's almost like that boat and you
couldn't discern it as people
claimed that you would feel the velocity
of the earth if it were really in motion
and so that was the notion that held
from aristotle up until galileo
and so because of that galileo kind of
rebelled against it and
and started to say well no don't demand
that it's possible for us to determine
that we're in motion
from simply the motion or things that
could depend on your reference frame
and so uh uh what he instead tried to do
is argue that the motion of the earth
uh combined with its revolution on its
axis and its rotation about the sun
would cause a sort of sloshing effect
like in this cup of whiskey that i'm
holding up
that's good whiskey i actually have
behind me some simon's observatory
whiskey i don't know if you can see that
anyway that's not whiskey
something for the after show yeah it's
yeah it's not yet
it's only 9 00 a.m where i'm at i only
wait till i'm just kidding
um so going back to the slides uh
so their thing stood for a very long
time and in fact the true explanation
for the earth's tides has
nothing at all to do with the motion of
the earth around the sun
or around its axis instead it's caused
by the tidal gravitational pull
of the moon and so it was interesting
that galileo some believe
that he knew that to be the case but the
argument kind of the
visceral appeal of that argument that i
just did with this cup of water
it was so persuasive not only to him but
he knew he could convince others of
his conjecture which is ultimately true
right christian it's true that the sun
is not going around the earth that's the
other way around so
is it okay for us to use like incorrect
logic to like establish something that
you know to be true and it must be true
no i don't think so
uh any more than it's good to lie to
people you know your kids or something
but you know
i'm a parent and i don't know how to do
stuff without bribing and lying and
all sorts of chicken but anyway that's
besides the point
so getting back to these slides so if
everything stood until newton you know
isaac newton didn't really add much to
this theory of relativity
he did add to the theory of gravity
which firmly established that the moon
caused the earth's tides but
getting back to relativity it really
wasn't until until
james clerk maxwell in the 1800s came up
with the theory of electrodynamics
so how electrical and magnetic waves
propagate
through space uh was governed by a term
that had
in effect the speed of light as the
propagation speed
and this brought up huge kinds of
intellectual dissonances
people just could not accept the fact
that a you could have
things traveling through a vacuum they
would say
well there must be some medium just like
there's water waves in the earth's tides
and in the
uh for for for water waves or air waves
uh carry sound waves are carried in a
medium they said so too
must maxwell's waves of light be carried
on some
substance otherwise you'd have this
spooky action at a distance so to speak
although that was reserved by einstein
for much much later
um and so what i found so interesting is
that
because of what uh galileo proposed
then when maxwell came along he was
really kind of stumped for a while
and it really fell to poincare and then
much later einstein
to come up with an idea that no it is
possible
for people to tell um to to
to do experiments that are occurring
near the speed of light
that violate galilean relativity in
other words
that you can simply add the velocity of
the ball to the velocity of the ship
einstein showed that with the postulate
of what's called lorentz and variance
which is that there's no preferred
reference frame in the universe
and another postulate which is that the
speed of light is the maximum possible
speed
of any transmittable information
physical body or object
or signal those two postulates
effectively allowed him to
uh to propose what became known as the
theory of relativity
and around that time there were
experiments being done actually at my
alma mater case western reserve
university in cleveland ohio cleveland
ohio uh there was an experiment done by
michelson and morley
to test whether or not there was a type
of
wave water-like medium through which
waves of light here from the sun for
example or from anywhere
that would support the oscillation of
waves of electricity and magnetism
and so they devised a test they said at
different times of the year
if there is this lumineferous ether and
it is it is
a region of of space in which the earth
is
uh you know it supports all oscillations
then the earth will be
traveling at different times with
respect to this lumineferous ether
and you could add the velocity of the
earth uh
in the uh to the velocity of the ether
in the spring or summer
and you could subtract that in the fall
and you should get different
values for the speed or for this this
particular uh
phenomenon would vary with time of day
as i said you can't
that is a forbidden fact in notions of
what's called lorenzen variance
so they devised the test which i show on
the next slide
which was actually done as i said at
case western which
used an interferometer i'm just showing
you because it looks kind of cute i'm
not going to get into too much detail
but they ended up getting a null result
meaning that they could not detect the
earth was moving
with respect to this ether this
lumineferous ether
so either there was some phenomenon
taking place
that conspired that throughout the year
the
measurement of the speed of light would
be constant either that was occurring
or there was no luminiferous ether so
i uh what i think is so interesting is
that in actuality one interpretation
that
uh sir martin reese lord martin reese
made on my
show into the impossible on my podcast a
couple months ago about a month ago
as he said if you think about that in
the context of galileo's
um adversaries they would have said
thanks for proving us right galileo
because it really could be used to show
that the earth is stationary
so isn't that ironic that you know this
this this cornerstone
in the theory of relativity of einstein
could have been used to refute
the claim that the earth is in motion
that's just kind of a cute and ironic
aside but the ultimate discovery by
einstein was that galileo's relativity
only held true at very low speeds and in
fact you have to augment that
when you want to test things at higher
velocities near the speed of light
and so what we're trying to do now is
not only
use phenomena that take place at very
great
energy levels perhaps the origin of the
universe i talked about the first time i
was on the show
but also look for uh
violations of this principle called the
principle
of lorentz invariance namely the
universe does not care
if you do a measurement in the spring or
the summer it doesn't know anything
about our local reference frame
because it is ultimately insignificant
unimportant and other things that my
older brother used to accuse me of
wow that's a that's a great introduction
to the so so
okay so now we are trying to
pro actually before i before i get any
further i do want to just acknowledge
just a couple comments
uh before i get to what i was going to
say and that is uh
well you know there's a few questions
i've come up to we're going to we're
going to come up to some questions
uh in a little bit and i'll just be
scrolling back
uh through these as best as i can uh but
uh what i'd like to just ask is that you
know we're looking toward the microwave
background
and we're trying to see because it's on
the one hand to a lay person it might
seem like oh well the microwave
background's got to be the ultimate
reference frame
after all it surrounds everything that
we see it is
it's it's permanent it's everywhere it's
uniform
two within one part of a hundred
thousand
you go right there's our ultimate
reference frame right
well you know people do say that um uh
quite often
and i always say there's no such thing
as a stupid question there's just stupid
questioners
uh no i'm just kidding christian that's
that's totally legitimate
i asked that question on purpose uh
so no it turns out that they that um
what we call
the cosmic microwave background is
better thought of
as an event rather than a
um an object so in the sense that
that the um the microwaves that we
detect
using telescopes like currently the
simon's array and upcoming
and bicep and then upcoming simon's
observatory
we are able to measure the print the
properties of the universe when it was
about 380
000 years old in the light and the
material composition
and whether or not there was exotic form
of radiation called gravitational waves
uh not unlike what ligo detected from
the collision of two black holes
that was the subject of my book and
that's the subject of our previous
conversation
now the question is is that reference
frame
absolute in other words can you tell
somebody to meet you at a certain day
at a certain time at a certain altitude
you know north latitude and longitude
can you use the cosmic microwave
background to do that
the answer is no because that
observation of how we perceive it is
unique in the sense to its actual
properties
in other words it's it's specific
temperature in that direction over here
versus that direction over there
depends on where we are on the earth
going around the sun
so in other words we see local effects
just like our galaxy
is very similar to about 100 billion
other galaxies but it's not identical to
any of them
so in other words the statistical
properties of these microwaves
as you say are independent they have a
certain characteristic
but we can no more say that we are able
to measure our position
and time with respect to the microwave
background
than to do so with respect to a given
explosion say
another event was the dropping of the
atomic bomb on on hiroshima
so that was an event that took place at
some space at some time
and and yet we cannot measure things
specifically
related to that in a way that holds true
on proxima centauri b
in other words those two times and those
two coordinate systems do not overlap
in a way that we can stitch together to
make a universal coordinate system
and the same is true not only within our
galaxy but within the entire
observable universe legit yep okay great
so then
how then can we use the cosmic microwave
background even if it is not
the ultimate reference frame how can we
probe that
to test these ideas so what we want to
do
is instead of looking for um and it's
not only the cosmic microwave background
i'll actually talk more about individual
sources as well
uh there was a claim recently that it
would be possible to measure
the violation of something called uh
parity symmetry
and parity symmetry is the other very
closely held belief
that physics should look the same in a
mirror in other words
if i show you a pendulum going back and
forth and i say uh actually christian
you were looking at that through a
camera so it's like a mirror image
you can't tell the difference the
physics is identical if you go
underneath the plane of the solar system
and look up
you would see planets going around
counterclockwise or or what have you
uh i believe counterclockwise from below
the plane of the of the galactic of the
of the solar system the ecliptic plane
now if you go above it you could say
well now they're going in opposite
direction so all you have to do is
reverse the direction of time
and then you get the same laws of
physics physics does not
have any dependence on absolute time
right
and it doesn't have dependence on
absolute uh left and right symmetry
for most laws of nature but it turns out
there is a principle known as the
violation of parity symmetry and
charge conjugation so these are there
are three different types of symmetries
if you change the uh an electron to a
positron
it will behave the same as an electron
with an electric field reversed
okay so that's charge symmetry uh parity
symmetry means that you
physics will look the same in a mirror
uh and and that you won't be able to
distinguish the physical
laws of a pendulum oscillating or a
spring vibrating or whatever
if you're looking at it in a mirror and
time invariance as i just said if you
change the direction of time
uh you should not actually be able to
tell that oh actually i'm running the
movie backwards when i show you this
pendulum you can't tell
what's happening what's forward and
what's backward so these are all
discrete what are called discrete
symmetries
turns out in the 1950s scientists
discovered
that there's a law of nature and it's
called the weak nuclear force
and the weak nuclear force does violate
two of these symmetries in other words
you can tell that you're
looking at physics of the weak force
which is nuclear decay
governs nuclear you can tell that the
cosmos
violates that in a very very subtle
fashion
by doing an experiment that was done in
1957 so this isn't like requiring like
the large hadron collider or something
this is very very and this is called
violation of of charge and parity
this was discovered in the 1950s
now there's something you might be
familiar with which is something called
the theory of everything have you ever
heard that
a few times yes yeah yeah so a theory
everything
i'm still working on it yeah exactly
that's right i usually ask my guests
when they come on my show
you owe me an appearance i this is now
the second time i've invited myself on
your show
so i want you to invite yourself on mine
okay i was on the show but i don't know
if i can
hold i don't know if i can hold the
camera with some of your other guests
this guy gets the best guess right here
and
and now he wants to have me on i
definitely want to have you on you
you're one of my role models and
inspirations but let's not get into it
mutual admiration
but back to that back to back to
mitchell back to theory of everything
so if you show the screen now uh that
i'm sharing
sure i will point out a couple of uh
facets here there
is a kind of uh set of blocks shown here
that are meant to kind of encapsulate
what we know about
the laws of physics so there are laws of
gravity at the top there's laws of
electromagnetism of chemistry there's
something called the standard model
that's the laws of particles forces and
fields that's shown up here
in the upper right corner the quarks the
gluons
um the w bosons the neutrinos
all those forces we believe were once
unified together into what is typically
called
a theory of everything and that theory
of everything
could be um could be a true statement
about
how these forces become one at very very
high energy scales which translates to
very very early times
we don't know if that's true we have
reason to suspect that that's true
and and i have several videos from this
past summer
with pbs space time studios where we
asked leading contenders for theories of
everything
to kind of go through their arguments
and attack their competitors it was
really fun
so check that out on my channel
wonderful series
so the question of of whether or not
it's possible to
to um to look for deviations
so now if we go to this diagram and i
slightly break
this assumption that the universe
doesn't care about you
that doesn't care what day it is doesn't
care where you live doesn't care what
you look like
that will have downstream effects it
will have effects that ripple
through potentially to allow test for
the existence of this tiny violation of
lorenz symmetry
far far downstream potentially in the
realms that i
traffic in namely cosmology and
astrophysics it may also have
implications for gravity in that we
would see it
manifest uh itself in a very interesting
way via gravitational waves like ligo
would make
different detection if you will on a
monday versus a tuesday in a way that
i'll explain in just a bit
so this is the underpinning if we can
find
a downstream effect in astrophysics and
in the la
or in the laboratory some deviation that
elucidates
the violation of lorentz symmetry it
would perhaps have
you know even greater ramifications than
whether or not the universe began
with an inflationary big bang as we and
i talked about last time
so this would be new physics it would
mean that the laws of the standard model
of particle physics
of gravity of gr would have to be
modified at a very very deep fundamental
level
so we should look for it that would be
that would be something else because i
mean it's not the first time we've seen
competiting uh competitive theories to
general relativity
uh one of the ones and i can't remember
who the author of it was
uh offered uh basically gave a
colloquium
at the when i was at the university
saying
here's my theory and he talks about all
these wonderful parameters that he can
tweak
just to get to everything it's a way to
say if your theory requires you to
tweak parameters to arrive at a specific
that's not a theory so how can how can
something like this be tested
you know straight you might say like
what would be a
i mean this is an interesting prospect
and i know brian sorry i've got
yeah yeah i uh can you hear me still it
went a little quiet
uh i'm sorry can you hear me yeah okay
now i hear you yeah yeah i'm sorry i was
muted
that's okay um uh yeah uh-huh
well yeah well you you too
elisa because you're watching us
you can join me okay then uh chris we
got you good yep
okay great so uh back to what we can
actually say
and why it's so important so we think
that the universe obeys these
fundamental
dearly held principles that doesn't stop
people
from conjecturing ways that we could
violate
this principle and in some sense perhaps
elucidate how the theory of gravity gets
unified with the three
higher energy forces electromagnetism
the weak force
and the strong nuclear force and i
should say as an aside
we do know that electricity and
magnetism are unified
electromagnetism is the name we gave to
that that's what maxwell did
uh in the 1960s a past guest on my show
sheldon glashow and stephen weinberg and
abdus salam
showed how the weak nuclear force
is actually another manifestation of
electromagnetism
at high high energies so that was called
su-2
unification and now and that was the
electro that was the electro weak
theory that yes that we now have so i
just told you that in the 1950s people
showed that the weak
uh the weak force violates parity
then you should expect that perhaps
maybe at high enough energies and you
can read that as
early times that the electromagnetic
force
would manifest parity violation and how
would you detect that
well you might see the following
phenomenon you might see
in the early universe an explosion that
is
polarized produces polarized light
ignore how that occurs it's known to
happen
in the microwave background it's known
to happen with um
with supernovae explosions as well and
in fact it could happen with
gravitational waves
emitted from the coalescence of black
holes for example
now imagine these waves of light are
produced and
one polarization in other words one
orthogonal component of the
electromagnetic field
the light in that polarization arrives
in your camera
one second before the light arrives in
the horizontal polarization that would
be a manifestation
of parity violation which itself
would not necessarily violate lorenzen
variants
but you can trivially modify the laws of
maxwell to do both parity and lorenz
violation and that's been a claim that
was discovered not
not just once in the history of
cosmology not just once in the history
of my career in cosmology
but so far about three or four times
people have claimed
including at the end of last year that
the universe
disobeys parody symmetry in
electromagnetism
based on observations of either radio
galaxies or the cmb
and perhaps it violates parity symmetry
or lorenz invarian symmetry as well so
we start to look for that
and it turns out the deeper i go into it
the more
kind of unusual and the more interesting
the implications of the measurements
that i'm doing
turn out to be in other words we may be
able to get at the heart of these
questions
using both the cosmic microwave
background and
looking at these distant objects that
are called radio galaxies or
quasars and they may illuminate
what the properties or the symmetry
properties of nature really
are and to what extent they are violated
that's
remarkable that is uh and i and i'd like
to ask
about yeah i i because i know you got
like someplace you want to go with this
and so i want to let you get there but i
also want to kind of talk about
how you go about actually doing that
what what these observations would look
like what these experiments would look
like
first though i do i do see something in
the comments and i want to give a shout
out to
james overdoing a good friend of mine
from towson university
uh constraints on lawrence variation are
very strong if we strengthen them
further and still find nothing theorists
will simply move the goal posts
is there a level beyond which we can
stop looking great question
what do you think brian well uh i agree
i'm an observer not a theorist
however there are um actually had a
conversation today on my channel i
recorded an interview with carlo revelli
so if you go over to the to this
powerpoint to the
keynote slides yeah you'll see a bunch
of book covers
and some of them are involving these uh
this particular type of theory of
quantum gravity
known as loop quantum gravity
and loop quantum gravity has been around
for a really long time
it's it's a a true contender along with
string theory
for a possible way to unify gravity
with quantum mechanics and that's the
holy grail that
i think is is interesting to probe now
the limits are strong they're strong in
the laboratory
uh but they claim and this is the claim
of carlo ravelli that i
had on my show which will come out
hopefully the next few weeks on the into
the impossible podcast
that actually the lorentz uh invariance
violation
uh that was predicted uh to occur
and and claimed not to exist is actually
not that strong
according to carlow in other words the
tests that have been done
do not really rule out this effect in a
meaningful way
and the effect that was that was claimed
to be this positive to kind of
refute the loop quantum gravity's claim
he involved what's called a gamma-ray
burst so very energetic
explosion uh of an object at a very high
redshift
uh very early times in the universe's
history
and that produced photons of many
different colors including
very long wavelength photons in the red
end of the gamma ray spectrum
and very short wavelength in the blue
end of the spectrum and
these photons according to the uh the
the claims that were made by uh by
those that were probing this effect
using the fermi satellite
was that the red photons would arrive
later than the blue photons
so in other words you could test the
energy dependence which is one of the
terms
of the so-called violation of lorenzen
variants would involve
violating the independence of energy in
other words the speed of light
should not depend on what color light
you're using that is a form
so carlo today and elsewhere has claimed
that no
it's actually not true that the universe
uh
has been shown not to have this effect
and in fact he thinks it's alive and
well
in quantum gravity of the loop variety
and this is after accounting for all the
effects of extinction dispersion
he still feels that there is oh wow
that's fascinating
okay this is the first i've heard of
this so this is this is news
i'm hearing it here it was a great
conversation yeah it should be out
fairly soon and and of course he has a
deep interest in this because
you know one of the notions that this
can impact in on is
sort of a notion of time and and how
time is measured and to what extent time
is
absolute relative the different types of
time
uh that people talk about how we
experience time and so
uh it is true uh to your to your
listener is very astute
there but there's actually a rich
literature and every three years there's
a conference held at
uh indiana university and it's by one of
the leaders in this field
and they look at the literally 800
different ways or more
that you could violate the standard
model of electromagnetism by adding a
parity and lorentz violating term
and there's 800 different ways or more
to do so and
very few of them have been ruled out
definitively
okay um but then again they've also not
yet been
ruled in as almost like the simple
contra positive but you know what i mean
like
have it been any yeah so like what
experiments are being done
to and we can't talk about every single
one of them but but i would like to talk
about
what how the experiment would work like
what would you actually be looking for
would this be another bicep 2 type of
experiment
would this be something else tell me
what you yeah there are ways to look for
this effect
in the microwave background um and
um i'll uh i'll skip over the math
because i think it's a little bit
it's a little bit uh pedantic but uh
it's just cute
in one sense because it involves the
very man who's funding the simon's
observatory namely this guy
jim simons uh he came up with a concept
in mathematics known as a churn simon's
invariant which is really a a
a an object that belongs properly in
in geometry and differential geometry
and manifolds and topology
but for various reasons it became
possible
to uh to have application in
not only uh string theory which ed
whitton has used this chern simon's term
uh i'm also trying to get ed whitton on
the show but so far he's my
he's my impossible get to get um into
the impossible but we'll see i'll keep
working on them
i don't give up that easily ed if you're
out there i know you're listening
and so uh but it also has implications
for cosmology
so string theory and cosmology together
um they offer ways for us to think about
and possibly constrain
the existence or lack thereof of these
exotic effects so i want to point out
what we're doing here at uc san diego
with colleagues at mit and elsewhere
to to really unravel uncover decode
whether or not you could measure such an
effect
using optical polarimetry now why is
this interesting
because an optical experiment can cost
one percent
of the cost of a microwave experiment or
one billionth of a percent
of a space telescope like the fermi
telescope in fact some of your listeners
might be able to help in such a campaign
i do want to take the advertisement
opportunity to ask you to sign up for my
newsletter bryankeeting.com
you'll get a lot of cool information
you'll get links to interviews with jim
simons with shelly glashow with frank
wilceck
and i also have a giveaway for to win a
book
by frank wilcheck who is just on my show
who has a term of his own which violates
uh cp variants called an axion we're not
going to get into that
but i do want to mention that for you
amateur astronomers out there
we are working with a very talented
amateur astronomer
he's also an alumni of case western
university it turns out named gary cole
anyway he lives
in western nevada outside of reno nevada
and he and i have become friends
and we've been using his very sensitive
but amateur built polarimeter that's
shown there
to measure these effects for objects
known as blazars
which are a form of active galactic
nucleus
and by measuring them over the over the
entire sky we can look for effects that
are both
very distant and so sample a large
fraction of the cosmic volume
was shown by this funnel kind of shaped
thing over here this is the wmap picture
of the universe's evolution
but we can look for these lorentz and cp
violating
effects that would be the hallmark of
new physics
so i'll just go over this very briefly
this is a team uh
very tragically unfortunately my good
friend and colleague andy friedman who
is the leader of this project
passed away from a series of of
illnesses
um of this past summer in 2020 so we
dedicate everything
we're doing in this project to his
memory and to his legacy
yeah he was just turned 41 uh and he was
a real giant uh and just a hilarious
humorous
good-natured uh you know individual who
uh did so much not only for me but he
also mentored this young man over here
isaac browdy
who is now a freshman at uc berkeley up
north
and isaac won the uh the san diego
science fair
under the tutelage of andy friedman and
myself and also came in fourth in the
whole state of california
based on the project what we did
together so he was a mentor he was a
friend
he was a giant of a scientist so in his
memory we are continuing this term and
and really what it comes down to
schematically is we can look for
violation
of the standard model of physics
using distant objects in this case using
objects known as blazars
and mapping their positions on the sky
looking at their polarization properties
seeing how they vary in space and in
time and looking for preferred reference
frames
and in so doing we can limit both
lorentz invariants violating terms here
or cpt charge parity and time violating
symmetry terms here and
i won't go into the details of how many
different terms that i already mentioned
there could be literally you know 10 to
the third different ways that you could
violate and so far escape current bounds
but what's shown here is why it's so
interesting because you might
see effects such as those predicted
by loop quantum gravity namely the
discretization
of space-time itself so carlo revelli
lee smallin abe ashtakar and others
conjecture that we've been going about
quantum gravity
all wrong we've been trying to make
gravity quantized
but really the thing that is quantized
is space time
itself and in so doing
you can make laws that are
self-consistent that
seem to agree with some data but but
have challenges with others
but compared to string theory which has
had 10 to the third
more people working on it and 10 to the
third more dollars devoted to it
it's very promising and i i really
encouraged by my conversation with
carlow and lee smallin and others
that it's something to look at because
if you could find this planck scale
features
um the only hope you could find them uh
of finding them perhaps is when the
universe was about the plank size
plank size i should remind you is about
10 to the minus 35 meters
so we're looking for you know quite
small uh uh
distances and the speed of light
you know the plank time is that distance
you know divided by the speed of light
and so it's it's incredibly small it's
10 to the minus 40 third of a second
so uh these are really just
infinitesimal amounts but what's so good
about that christian
is that it eliminates and alleviates
the need for these so-called
singularities that develop
in uh in quantum gravity typically
because you
can never get to zero if we're if we're
describing space-time
as okay it's quantized there's a minimum
length to the
there's a minimum length of the universe
there's a minimum amount of time
you never divide by zero you never
divide by zero i've always wondered
about unlike how i do my taxes you know
yeah
i've always wondered about that which is
not to say that i'm like
genius but i've always thought to myself
okay can't we just treat the
space the plank the plank lengths and
the plank times
as discrete units in the universe and
it's
it's exciting to see that there's a line
of work that's heading in that direction
absolutely so yeah i know we only have a
little bit of time left i do just want
to kind of cut to the chase but um
so what we're looking for with these
very small telescopes let me just show
you these telescopes here so we're
looking for these objects active
galactic nuclei
sometimes called blazars or bl lac
objects they're highly polarized
check that means we have another
dimension or two dimensions
over which we can look for violations or
these
ciphered galaxies etc i'm sure your
listenership
is astute and they will know about it we
built the small polarimeter my colleague
gary cole
class of 1969 i think he was
or 60 i forget what he was anyway he's
about
50 it was graduated 50 years ago so
we'll figure out how old he is but
anyway
he built this telescope he's basically
just a retired software engineer who
moved from the bay area
uh from silicon valley to western reno
and lives up in the mountains at about
2000 meters elevation takes these
spectacular images
with this robotic array of amateur
telescopes no this guy this is not
amateur this guy's got game
i mean this is like i know what you mean
he he's an unpaid professional let's put
it that way
he's not using the keck telescope he's
you know he's these are
these are celestron telescopes right he
knows how to do it yes
and he knows how to analyze data he's
not you know he doesn't understand the
theory as well as andy did or
you know i i hope to but he's incredibly
astute as an observer
and he's taken part in observations of
variable stars of polarized stars and so
forth
that uh for campaigns that last two
decades
in other words he's looking at this
particular star in polarized light
over 20 years to see its full cycle of
variability he's just a phenomenal
person and so we've made constraints and
two papers
this one i'm incredibly proud of because
this one i had a
help get through after andy's untimely
passing this summer
and so again we dedicated this in his
memory this is a tour de force this
paper
um you know every day i get people
asking me to like can you also publish a
version of your paper and you know i'm
like it's andy's paper
you know in some book or some journal
and so we made a complete
catalog in different colors in different
wavelength bands and in different
polarizations of what is known about
these objects
all over the sky because as i said you
might want to look for a preferred
direction
a reference frame that is universal
allegedly in other words that the vacuum
of space time singles out a particular
direction
would be a way to violate lorenzen
variants we don't see that
so far but again there are many many
different types of terms
there's many permutations of terms in
other words you can look for
polarized green light um or you can look
for
unpolarized violet light you know so
there's all these different permutations
of polarization
of frequency then you could take the
frequency which is proportional to
energy
and you can ask if space time has more
than you know three dimensions of space
in one of time
what would the effect be on a photons
energy how would that change the photons
energy so therefore
we look for energy or wavelength
dependent effects and there's an
infinite number of them because you can
just take
the energy raise it to whatever power
you want and uh and you can set limits
as you say on any of those what's so
spectacular about these
searches that andy pioneered is that
with the
simple uh uh instruments not simple in
the in the sense but like inexpensive
instruments
that gary put together called apple we
are able to set limits on these
terms that are competitive with a
professional 3.6 meter diameter
telescope that's bigger than the hubble
telescope by a meter
and and we're doing this you know
literally with no money
uh and just the love and that's what
amateur means right chris it means
i mean absolutely yes absolutely and i
know you have a lot of lovers out there
uh and so stay tuned for this uh the
this is the next generation is really
going deep and looking for what are
called systematic effects but i'm happy
to take more questions
yeah sure a couple of questions here uh
okay
so uh and i'm probably not gonna um
okay do any of these theories about
everything toes
trying to salvage three dimensions of
space one dimensional timer they all
operate to some
assuming higher dimensions or hidden
variables or something
yeah very good question so the answer is
is they do have other dimensions in fact
some of the most promising according to
string theory
are so-called 10-dimensional models
where you have nine dimensions of space
uh one dimension of time and even more
so than that
so-called what's called ads cft uh
there's a professor at the institute for
advanced study who is
which is einstein's you know final
resting place so to speak
uh where he did his final work uh that
was essentially based on um you know
whether or not
you could uh make a theory of everything
that would unify all the forces of
nature uh in a gravitational
fashion in other words in a purely
geometric fashion a gravitational
incorporating gravity and all the other
laws as we know in terms of gravit
the geometry of the theory of
the strong force and the weak force and
electromagnetism are all governed by
what are called gauge groups
the thought was you could unify all of
them together in a get in a giant gauge
group and this still goes on so my
friend eric weinstein who's been on my
show
many times he has a theory that there
are 14 dimensions of space-time
um there is a theory by garrett lesi who
believes there's a fundamental theory
that he calls e8
uh which is eight-dimensional
exceptional lead groups
and so lisa randall uh and her colleague
ramen sundrum who's not too far away
from you christian they believe that
there's five dimensions
what's called randall syndrome gravity
um so yes the answer to the question is
absolutely there's
more dimensions than meets the eye for
many of these theories of everything
but we have no evidence that such a
dimensionality is needed
and that's why things like loop quantum
gravity are of interest to me because it
doesn't require
more than three space plus one time
fantastic
great answer thank you so much brian and
by the way i forgot to acknow
i was scrolling back up while you were
talking brian just to look for other
questions
i saw this really generous super chat
from pathmatic thank you so much before
i get together get called out thank you
for
i'm sorry i'm calling you out i'm sorry
but i just want to thank you
very much uh for the donation it really
does help and uh
yeah super chats are gleefully accepted
uh and appreciated unless you're a
student of mine in which case you're
you're poor and i don't want your money
but uh thank you so much
take it pat okay uh let's get to another
question here
and i know i saw it if you put and i did
say if you can put a cue in front of
your question i
realize i kind of got that in a little
bit late but uh
you know let me i did see one other
question
uh from dragarth one thoughts on
wolfram's hypergraph framework with
continuous
variable dimensionality which unify gr
with quantum
through adding a space of i can't say it
all one breath
i know about it because i had him on my
show and if you look behind me
there is i've had on everybody except
edward whitten ed
please hit me up you got my number come
on um
uh so i have stephen uh i actually had
stephen and i had eric
uh separately and together eric
weinstein and they battled it out in
what i call the toe to toe battle
get it but uh but the the essence that
we came to
is that uh the unique thing about
stephen
wolfram's ideas in his physics project
which is
over here behind me um is that the
universe yes is described by this by
this
super space of of essentially what
appear to be like a cellular automata
that he calls bronchial space or
branchial space
and that the branching of of space-time
occurs
on a an extremely radically fast pace
and that there are actually observable
signatures that could arise from it
and and those would be manifest in the
properties of
black hole coalescing to form
gravitational waves
so the question is a good one in that we
could possibly
test the at least the unification of
gravity with the other forces
uh in in wolfram's theory the uh the
problem is that some of the
timing and the and the techniques need
to do it are beyond what's
currently capable of being done so i
would say for now
uh as as much as i you know i'm
interested in that theory
we don't have yet a reason to believe
that these
these rules that he proposes are really
forming a basis not only for
uh for a theory of quantum gravity but
he claims for a theory of
everything which really means you know
unifying all the forces
and all physical phenomena into one
and uh actually dragarth has a follow-up
question which i think you may have
already addressed uh brian but
you know he also asks what about
variable dimensions where dimensionality
is a free parameter able to change via
phase transitions
this is the part that gives me the
heebie-jeebies because that's more
parameter tweaking but
uh yeah
i don't i don't have as much familiarity
with that um in
in in the context certainly of wolfram
but i will say that people like uh
hawking and james hartle uh did claim
that
effectively time uh is sort of
separated out from space in other words
it did it once went from a state where
you know what you call the future was
actually a spatial dimension and it's
not so far-fetched because that's
actually what happens inside
of a black hole all of your spatial
directions are actually
time-like towards the singularity so
so they have in the no boundary proposal
hawking and hartl
essentially a changing of the nature of
a dimension that we call time now
from having uh what they call considered
no boundary
to eliminate the need for a singularity
at the origin of our current observable
epoch of our universe okay great thank
you so much
and uh also uh hey shout out to the
exoplanets channel it's also another
great channel on youtube you gotta check
that out it's called
the exoplanets channel and a great live
it's good to have you on here man thank
you so much
let me just uh quickly double check a
couple of things here uh
okay oh so yeah here we go quick
question what is an answer to unlimited
energy and world domination physicists
should be able to answer that yeah no
problem
um yeah i uh i've i've got it
written down but it's over there and i'm
too lazy to go get mine
i have it in the margin of my book on
page 27. oh so there you go so it
checked the
it's all in the footnotes my friends saw
in the footnotes
i think that's a okay so we are just a
little bit past our time here i do want
to thank you again
so much brian for coming on the show
again you invited yourself no you didn't
come on i was looking forward to having
you back and we were just trying to
figure out the time to get you on and we
got you on and we made it work and thank
you so much for coming by
and i'd like to thank all of you so much
for
tuning in tonight and hanging out with
us and just as i close out here a little
bit
i just want to say a very quick shout
out and a gratitude to all of my patreon
supporters for helping to keep lunch pad
astronomy going
and especially to uh anna and travis
graham it's over they're over there
travis graham for their intergalactic
level support and michael dowling
stephen j morgan and morrison wild for
the cosmological level support now
if you'd like to just help make launch
pad astronomy work for the price of a
cup of coffee every month or please head
on over to my patreon page over there
and i'll get figure this out one day and
but anyway feel free to check that out
patreon.com
launchpad astro and as always if you are
interested in following along and
enjoying this journey to this incredible
universe of ours so please make sure you
subscribe and ring that notification
bell
so that you don't miss out on any new
videos
until next time i wish you all a very
wonderful uh at least for us here on the
east coast a very snowy evening
and please stay home stay healthy and
stay curious my friends
good night
you